protests underway for the seventh
consecutive day in new york state's
third largest city
they began last wednesday following the
release of the body cam footage of
daniel prude's arrest by police
police say prue told them he had
coronavirus and started spitting
at that stage they put what is called a
split bag over his head
prude died a week later and the medical
examiner ruled his death a homicide
now amidst the ongoing protests the
rochester police chief has resigned
claiming in a written statement that
there had been what he called
a mischaracterization and politicization
of his actions
following daniel pruitt's death the
early retirement
confirmed by the city's mayor while the
timing and tenor
of these resignations is difficult we
have
faced tough times before
i truly believe that we will get through
this
i will be meeting with city council to
chart a path forward
i can assure this community that i am
committed to instituting the reforms
necessary in our police department
i know that there are many questions but
this
just occurred and honestly i do not have
the answers today this is just the
latest wave of protests following police
action against african-american
individuals
there were nationwide demonstrations
following the killing of george floyd in
may this year
the 46 year old died after a white
police officer knelt on his neck
for more than seven minutes then a fresh
round of protests following the shooting
of jacob
blake in kenosha wisconsin on the 23rd
of last month
the 29 year old african-american was
shot in the back
several times during a rest in full view
of his children
sitting in his car blake is paralyzed
from the waist down
the u.s attorney general recently denied
there was systematic racism within the
police
making the claim that in his words it is
very rare for an
unarmed african-american to be shot by a
white police officer
the millions that throughout much of
this year have protested the police
killings of african-americans would
disagree
pointing at the death of daniel prude in
rochester
as yet another tragic confirmation of
independent statistics
that black americans are as much as ten
times more likely to be shot by police
than white ones mike hannah al jazeera
washington